let's get more on the Cavanaugh
situation from George Washington
University Law Professor Jonathan Turley
John thanks for being here thank you
quite some developments here where do
you think this is headed I think it's
heading to a public hearing right there
is a move to try to have some type of
closed hearing but I think we really are
past that the I think the Republicans
are accepting they're going to have to
have her testify and if she testifies
the expectation is that he will have to
testify and that's not going to be a
good situation for him because he can't
finish with a tie here you know if he
comes out and both of them are
believable to some and not others you
still have a situation where he could
bleed off two or three votes and that's
the margin that he has speaking of that
one of those votes is Senator Susan
Collins from Maine one of the
Republicans who has obviously some
concerns about the nomination but also
about this here's what she said just a
short time ago in order for me to assess
the credibility of these delegations
individuals come for the Senate
Judiciary Committee so essentially we
are looking at a Clarence Thomas
situation and Anita Hill we are but here
is the first nominee I know of that's
been accused of effectively attempted
rape
you know with Thomas it was sexual
misconduct here you have someone who's
saying that this is so this is a nominee
who tried to rape me he vigorously
denies that says he wasn't even at that
party he's having calls with staff
members on the Senate Judiciary
Committee clearly he's pushing back here
if Democrats believe this accuser for
him as a nominee does that mean that
they are going to start impeachment
proceedings if his nomination is pulled
because why would he be eligible for the
second highest court in the land right
that's the problem is that you can't
stop this train halfway through the bid
down the track if you believe he was he
is an attempted that he was a someone
who tried to do an attempted rape or
it's sexually assaulted an individual
it's hard to imagine he could be an
article 3 judge so the Democrats may
find themselves buying more than they're
bargaining for they would you know it
would seem rather incongruous to have
him remain on the DC Circuit if they're
denying you on this basis seat on the
Supreme Court how much does the 36 years
factor in that it was high school he
again pushes back hard that this never
happened but just the timeframe well
there is a there is a real fairness
concern here not just because this was
delayed since July it was would they
waited until just before the vote for
confirmation but they're also throwing
this controversy into the mix involving
witnesses that if they have any
recollection at all it's over three
decades old that takes time it takes
time to try to put together people
recollections and any type of evidence
that you have he doesn't have time right
now if they're gonna push this vote but
if they don't push the vote then they
push this process potentially past the
midterm elections which becomes another
political issue you wrote an op-ed for
the hill in which you wrote among other
things quote it is a good thing there is
not a Doppler radar for hypocrisy where
Washington would be in the midst of a
mandatory evacuation what do you mean
there well it's it's it's a curious
thing to see some of I testified during
the impeachment hearings for dude that
related to Bill Clinton back then there
wasn't this movement you have to believe
her it wasn't just her was them it was
multiple women came forward to Sela
Jones
Juanita Broderick claiming not just
sexual assault but rape they brought
forth evidence that they claimed
supported them on a contemporary basis
many of these same members did not say
that they had to believe them to the
contrary they were attacked and the
Republicans back then of course wanted
full disclosure and so you're already
half concluding bread Cavanaugh on judge
Starr's that's right and Cavanaugh
wanted not just disclosure but rather
vivid disclosures as to what Bill
Clinton did so everyone's effectively
going to switch sides in this which is
going to be rather daunting for people
to watch but watch they'll have to do
because it's unlikely that we will be
able to conclusively show that someone
is lying and someone's telling the truth
it'll be left to a credibility judgment
and you're gonna have to make
by what you see in that hearing so we
are at the beginning not the end of this
process
I'm favorite the the rather messy
beginning and it's going to be an even
Messier ending Jonathan as always thanks
thank you